the shield is not a typical weapon
shield is not used as an offensive
weapon often and in this movie you guys
really pin down the physics I mean there
was like a specific Jack Kirby panels
eyesight I recognize that we're kind of
being paid homage to that must've been
kind of fun because you don't really get
to see that on screen very often no in
our approach to that was listen he he's
been modernized now right t-this
character you may or may not know was
you know and in the first film who's it
created during world war two he was yea
90-pound weakling and then he got
injected with a super serum so it made
sense in the first film he had a very
traditional fighting style you know so
we call it the john sullivan fighting
style then he got frozen and he woke up
in modern times now it's been two years
since he woke up and if he's working for
the most covert organization in the
world he's probably going to be the most
highly trained soldier in the world and
now our soldiers they know how to fight
with extremely advanced techniques so we
figured look if we're gonna ground this
if the character did exist he would be
highly trained and that that that shield
would be a very offensive weapon for him
because his job is to cast incapacitate
terrorists or you know she said they
were getting pirates on a boat he's
dealing with very dangerous people
we're cinephiles you know we grew up
from an academic standpoint it's how we
fell in love with movies and that we
grew up in the 70s and obviously you
know whatever whatever it is that you
loved as a child has an emotional impact
on you through the rest of your life and
70 Soilers were were sort of a way that
we accessed filmmaking three days of the
Condor parallax view Marathon Man at
French Connection huge impact on us when
we were kids our Father I used to watch
The Late Show with us and those were on
there's like a steady diet of those on
The Late Show so we met with Marvel I
said they wanted to make Captain America
7 News political thriller II said well
let's you know we couldn't ask for
better I used to imagine them Steve
McQueen it's a character when I was a
kid because we'd give him a little bit
more bite we really like the challenge
of combining you know some political
thriller which needs to sort of vary you
know by its nature it needs to be very
relevant in in some and and real on some
level and those movies were often
executed in that manner with a rich
level of realism to them we like the
idea of hybrid in that with a fantasy
film you know with like although all
through our careers we like we like
combining like sort of seemingly and
congruous things and kind of seeing how
you how what kind of new tone you can
find when you do that and and it's sort
of been our recipe like even like back
with Arrested Development that sort of
the idea of like taking an absurdist
comedy and shooting it you know
mockumentary or a documentary reality TV
style you know our process is very loose
we just sort of have a non-stop dialogue
between ourselves and we don't have any
formal divisions we both kind of like to
do everything so we just you know I know
we've been doing it a while now it's not
something we have to think about too
much but I'm a j'en AI every directing
team probably works a little differently
just like every director works
differently you know individual
directors so I don't I just think it's a
function of personality and then that
somehow you turn that into process and
and that's we just have a very loose
easygoing process Kevin Feige runs
Marvel called us because he had watched
an episode of a show that we executive
produced called community which is a
comedy on NBC and that showed us a lot
of genre spoofing and we spoofed
action movies by doing them by having
like a show set at a community college
and the community college students
getting a big game of paintball warfare
and it and it makes fun of a bunch of
action films from the 80s he saw an
episode that we directed of that and
called us and said you know buddy come
on in and I think he kind of should be
doing action movies I think he liked the
the fact that we made fun of the genre
so well he thought maybe we could
actually you know do the genre take take
the designer seriously so I think he
approached us initially because he felt
like these guys understand comedy but
our big pitch to him
was listen ever gonna do a political
thriller you can't have the characters
constantly undermining the the stakes
with humor you know you lose all sense
of narrative propulsion so we said it
can't be situational humor it has to be
character based humor the characters can
make fun of each other there can be
relationship humor but the minute they
start making light of the situation
where you lose the audience and then you
know we're not making a political
thriller we're making a farce or you
know we're making something else so I
think this movie in particular we tried
to put a tamper around it a little bit
but at the same time you know it's a
comic book film you want to you want to
wink at the audience a little bit you
want them to be entertained and engaged
and and and we also say to look if
you're gonna go to the movies and pay
$18 now to watch a film it's great to
laugh and cry and care and be scared and
see good action and you want everything
you just don't want one thing my wife
says Chris Evans takes his shirt off so
ya what she gets for 18 bonus okay Chris
is a wonderful actor you he does an
amazing job of sort of finding the sweet
spot between like you know keeping the
character in that sort of ethical mode
that he he exists in but also you know
giving him a little bit of texture and
bite and personality within that within
that mold I mean we we thought about how
do you frame a narrative around a
character like this because Captain
America he doesn't really have an arc he
doesn't change that much he's you know
he has sort of his he's all about just
sticking to his principles I mean we
were thinking you know how do you
fashion a narrative around that a good
story around that we started to think
about other characters who had who were
sort of similar in their sort of simple
sort of framing and code he's thought
about Rocky Balboa a lot you know and
just and just thinking cuz it really
it's all about for these characters all
you all they want to do is persevere you
know what I mean so it's sort of so it's
your job as a storyteller to like make
that as hard or as unlikely as you
possibly can and that's that's where
you're gonna maximize the fun and the
storytelling so our job in the movie was
just to sort of figure out how do we
keep tightening the screw on cap keep
you know frame um as an underdog may
keep them isolated but keep them
fighting and then just beat the hell out
of them Robert Redford expressed
interest in it and and these guys talked
him into it and it was incredible
because we were doing our 70s political
thriller inspired superhero movie so
it's one of those cases where the timing
is unbelievable because we've been
talking about three days of the Condor
all of these films all the President's
Men and then we got just a random phone
call saying Robert might be entering
something like this we might you have
anything and I thought oh boy do we ever
really wow that's a good did you think
you were getting pranked or no I didn't
but I thought I thought it was still a
shot in the dark even though we thought
this would be incredibly perfect that
the odds were slim
but thankfully because of the script and
because of the presentation these guys
did he agreed to he agreed to do the
part one of the things we learned from
70s thrillers is you know when you look
at the French Connection the car chase
is so brilliant that movie because it
illuminates character it it's about it's
about the character that he is so
determined to prove himself right that
he'll run over a woman with a baby
carriage in order to stop a guy on a
speeding train and that's the that's the
you know that that action for us has to
illuminate character illuminate theme
otherwise yes it can become incredibly
redundant and boring and these movies
are known for their spectacles so you
you want to try and find a way that you
know their broad audience appeal films
that you can appeal to all spectrums of
the audience people who want to find
something interesting in the movie will
have some thumb attics that they can
think about people who don't want to
think about thematics they're not having
a champ on the throat each movie needs
to stand alone and be a great you don't
need to be you don't need to do any
homework before you come see the movie
if you've seen the other movies maybe
they're things you'll notice and
appreciate but we really make the movie
for both for people who are following
along and for people who have no idea
what anybody's talking about and just
want to have a fun time at the movies